Elon Musk in February of 2021 was on Joe
Rogan's podcast and Rogan asked him what
is the deal what's the deal with Bill
Gates explain to me what Bill Gates was
talking about when he was saying that
you can't do trucks
yeah I didn't know what you're talking
about why did he say that then like why
would someone probably somebody told him
that and you know he just repeated it
he's just not that close to the physics
of it and so it was because I don't
think it was Ill intentioned here he
just doesn't know what he's talking
about but why say it then if you think
about a guy who's so involved in
technology you would think you would
only talk about things you understand
I don't know it's weird I also heard
that at one point he had a big short
position against Tesla which was kind of
I don't know if that's true or not but
it seems weird
uh people I know who know know the
situation well they they said are you
sure they said yeah he's a big short
position against Tesla which obviously
didn't work out too well
um but anyway I I think he's generally
got good intentions here I think he's
probably just not um well I don't hate
Bill Gates to be clear I think it's just
probably doesn't know the science yeah
the short version of that whole
conversation is Bill Gates is involved
in a whole bunch of things that he is
not an expert in there is no reason that
you nor I or anyone you know should be
listening to Bill Gates when it comes to
climate or covid or anything else he's a
tech guy he's a tech guy and again
without the glibness he did create
Windows okay that's great he did do that
he created Microsoft huge company made a
lot of money that's just fine but
somehow he has weaseld his way into
every facet of American life this is a
problem
[Music]
foreign
[Music]